China's Shanghai Disneyland reopened
this morning more than three months
after the corona virus pandemic forced
it to close the theme park experience
now includes temperature screenings
sanitizer stations and rules for social
distancing rainy Inocencio reports on
Disney's new normal and how soon we
might see it in this country Mickey and
Minnie Mouse took the stage as a band
played while a cast of other well-known
Disney characters greeted thousands of
guests all arriving for the parks
official reopening since it closed in
January but in a post pandemic era a
different experience awaits visitors to
enter Shanghai Disneyland now infrared
cameras with facial recognition software
scan each person for possible fever a
personalised QR code shows up on each
person smartphone only those with green
codes are allowed in once inside social
distancing is obvious everywhere yellow
tape or paint on the ground guides
visitors to keep at least three feet of
distance between each other tables are
cordoned off at restaurants that only
accept contactless payment no cash even
the most popular rides launch half full
and the precautions don't stop with
social distancing workers continuously
spray disinfectant and hand sanitizer
can be found almost everywhere but some
of the parks most popular attractions
are still dark including the main street
parades concerts and the nightly
fireworks show and with attendance
capped at about a third of the parks
capacity some guests say they welcome
the changes
the same is true here at Tokyo
Disneyland the gates are shut and Mickey
and Minnie and let alone anyone else for
that matter is nowhere to be found in
Japan's state of emergency has been
extended until the end of this month but
in Orlando there are signs of life
Disney Springs which is an outdoor
entertainment and shopping complex is
set to start a phased reopening on May
20th for CBS this morning
rainy innocencio Tokyo the smaller
crowds are nice the new rules may be
coming to a theme park near you Gail
that's okay I just think Anthony all
think Disney just makes me so happy I
watched that Disney sing-along last
night I felt like I was ten going along
with the words again so to see Disney
coming back however slow is a good sign